High alert
on the
Israeli-Lebanese border
after dozens of rockets
were fired from Lebanon
into Israel earlier today.
Israel says many,
but not all of them were intercepted
and it has now closed down
its northern airspace.
This latest episode comes after Israeli
forces stormed the Al-Aqsa
Mosque one of Islam's holiest sites
for the second time late last night.
Now, Israeli
police say they entered the mosque
after, quote, dozens of law
breaking juveniles
threw fireworks and stones
and barricaded themselves inside.
All of this happening
during a holy period for both Islamic
and Jewish faiths.
Elliot King is in Jerusalem for us.
Eliot,
bring us up to speed
on where things
stand on the ground right now,
beginning with the latest
round of rocket fire
Abbi, just this hour, we've received
more reports
from the IDF
that there were three mortars
fired from southern Lebanon.
Towards the town of Metula in Israel's
far north near the border.
And this,
as you say,
followed a barrage
of some three dozen
rockets fired towards Israel
from southern Lebanon earlier today.
That's the biggest barrage
since war,
a war between Israel
and the Iranian backed militants
of Hezbollah in 2006.
But it's very important to note
that Israel, the way we spoke
with the
international spokesperson
from the IDF, Richard Hecht,
and he says that they believe
that it was either Hamas
or Palestinian Islamic Jihad
that was responsible for firing towards
Israel from southern Lebanon.
In other words, it wasn't Hezbollah.
And that's significant
because if it was Hezbollah
and then Israel presumably
will at some point retaliate,
it says that
it will decide on the place
and time of its response.
Right now, it hasn't responded.
Contrary to earlier reports,
if it was Hezbollah
and then Israel responded towards
Hezbollah, positions,
then that could potentially
see things escalating,
perhaps towards the level
that we saw the last time.
There was an all out
war between the two sides in 2006
the fact that it's from
Palestinian factions
should suggest that the response
will be somewhat more measured Abbi.
All right.
Eliot Cohen, thank
you very much for that report.
And for more on this now,
let's bring in Dennis Ross.
He's a longtime peace
negotiator under Republican
and Democratic administrations,
including serving
as a former special Middle East
coordinator under President Clinton
and a special assistant
under President Obama.
He's now a counselor
at the Washington Institute
for Near East Policy.
Dennis, thanks for joining us.
First to start,
can you just give us your reaction
to what we have seen transpire in Israel
over the last two days?
Well, look, we are
we always knew that the reality
of having Ramadan
on one hand and Passover on the other
take place at the same time.
Was bound to create
a real potential for violence,
especially triggered
by those who would like to see violence.
We know that those who
barricaded themselves
within the Oscar mosque last night
had the very real purpose
of wanting to trigger something.
We know what's happened now.
It was not Hezbollah
that launched these rockets from Lebanon.
It was Hamas.
And as Hamas is launching from Lebanon,
it's not launching from Gaza.
There were a couple that were fired,
but they're basically trying
to shift the focus.
It signals that they don't want
war over Gaza,
but they also feel that
it was constrained
by what it can do in Lebanon
because of Hezbollah.
Hezbollah itself
allows Hamas to operate
and then claims
it had nothing to do with this.
So all of this suggests
that we're at a point
where there's great potential
for escalation
if one side or the other miscalculates.
Yeah.
I mean, I think to that point,
how likely is it, given
where we are right now,
that this could spiral out of control?
What would that even look like?
I think Israel undoubtedly
will respond
to the fact
that there were three
dozen rockets
fired out of southern Lebanon
and at least three mortar
shells fired into the city.
The town of Matula in the north.
So Israel will retaliate.
They will probably try to retaliate
in a way that hits
only those areas
where Hamas was operating if they hit
targets that Hezbollah considers
to be theirs, Hezbollah,
then that Hezbollah
may then
decide
that they will fire rockets into Israel.
If the two of them begin
an exchange that can easily spiral
out of control quickly.
Hezbollah can hit Israel
with 3000 rockets a day
for several weeks.
Israel won't take that.
They will end up going into Lebanon
on the ground to try to stop that.
So you can see how quickly
this could escalate
and get out of control.
My guess is neither
side wants to get out of control,
so it probably won't be
something that escalates that way.
But there's clearly a danger.
As I said,
calculations always seem great.
When you're in the abstract
or in the laboratory.
When real fire begins, a lot of things go
out the window.
Yeah, it
remains a very dangerous
and volatile situation right now.
Former Ambassador
Dennis Ross,
thank you very much for joining us.